we just heard seconds ago the sentence
come in two life sentences for Alec
murdal murdal had absolutely no reaction
as the judge sentenced him we heard the
judge say a little bit before that to
Alec Myrtle I'm sure you see Maggie and
Paul every night when you sleep Alec
murdal said every night I also spoke
with two of Maggie murdal's friends this
morning who say this is the Justice
they've been hoping for the defense
could appeal this guilty verdict but
even if they were successful murdal
could face life in prison for his
alleged Financial crimes some of which
he admitted to in this trial Tony
two killed in Cold Blood two life
sentences for those murders Nikki
Batiste thank you very much